so my wife and I have two young children
and like many of you we are terrified
about what the worst impacts of the
climate crisis are going to be for them
in their
lives do we
honestly have a plan that's specific
that's achievable that's actionable
that's going to allow us to reduce
Missions at scale with the speed that's
necessary to respond to the
catastrophe in time to improve the
quality of life for our
kids we've decided to focus and devote
our time and attention to the challenge
of Greening buildings in America and
I'll tell you a little bit about
why there are 125 million buildings in
America Coast to Coast these buildings
are where we cook and eat and work and
pray and raise our kids a lot of us
spend almost 90% of our time indoors in
buildings and these buildings are
powered by fossil fuels we burn coal and
gas at power plants we B burn oil and
gas in buildings this is a furnace uh
that produces hot water and heating uh
this is an apartment complex in in
Harlem that we visited back in 2014 and
I remember visiting it I was I was a
little worried because we could smell
gas kind of leaking and a few blocks
away a few weeks before this visit an
apartment building had a gas furnace
that exploded it collapsed the entire
apartment building a collapsed the
apartment building next door and eight
people died so I remember looking at
this boiler and taking a picture and
thinking get me the heck out of
here so because fossil fuels power our
125 million buildings it's 30% of
emissions 30% of American emissions are
tied to our buildings and there is no
actionable path to responding to the
climate crisis without going building by
building and Greening all of the
existing buildings in
America so I'm denell beard I'm the CEO
of block power we are a technology
company that focuses on moving buildings
off of fossil fuels we want to make
buildings smarter healthier Greener and
we want to do that by making buildings
100%
electric we're here in Detroit Detroit
is learning how to rip fossil fuel
engines out of vehicles and replacing
them with smarter all electric engines
we want to do the same thing for
buildings we want to rip out all the
fossil fuel equipment and replace it
with smart green all electric equipment
and we want that equipment to be powered
by electricity that's clean Stanford
Professor Mark Jacobson has written a
plan for all 50 states to be powered by
wind by hydroelectric power by solar
state by state so that our entire grid
can be
clean I got focused on the dangers The
Perils of fossil fuel systems growing up
as a kid with my family in a one-bedroom
apartment in Brooklyn we didn't have a
heating system that worked in our
apartment building in Brooklyn so when
it got really cold in the winters my
parents sometimes they work nights they
would tell me look if it gets too cold
light a match turn on the gas oven open
up the oven door and don't forget to
open up a window because Heat's going to
come into the apartment but so is carbon
monoxide and we don't want you to
suffocate then they go to
work and millions of Americans across
the country Heat their buildings this
way in the winter and worse but it's not
just the low-income buildings that are
super dangerous with fossil fuel and
infrastructure recent studies
indicate that gas ovens gas heating
systems in our home leak Benzene they
leak methane they leak nitrogen
dioxide there's so much nitrogen dioxide
emitted into American homes that it
causes about 133% of chronic childhood
asthma there's so much methane leaked
into our homes that it's equal to the
emissions of
500,000 gas- powerered vehicles and
Benzene Ben is a carcinogen and the
latest studies from Stanford indicate
that Benzene is emitted into our homes
it spreads throughout the home it
lingers we breathe it
in and it actually can be worse than
breathing in secondhand cigarette
smoke and so for any parent the thought
of our children sleeping and breathing
all the stuff in it's
horrific
but good news it's 2023 we don't live in
ancient Mesopotamia we no longer have to
dig up dead dinosaurs from the ground
and burn them in our buildings for
energy we got
options this is an electric induction
oven that uses electricity and induction
power of magnets uh it's hyper efficient
it's safe the finest chefs in the world
are starting to use these ovens and
systems they can boil hot water in less
than 60 seconds pretty awesome and one
of the new technologies and I'm really
exced excited about is the coal climate
heat pump coal climate heat pumps are
like a silver bullet for reducing
emissions in buildings we can now do
things that we could not do 5 years ago
because of this technology they use
electricity and refrigerant and
compressors to pump hot air into your
home in the winter to pump hot air out
of your home during the summer to heat
up hot
water but most importantly it allows us
to fundamentally unhook buildings from
fossil fuels we can unplug all of our
buildings and homes homes from fossil
fuels entirely due to these
systems so let's let's go back to my
building in
Brooklyn we now have a mix of
technologies that we can install in our
building solar panels on the roof high
efficiency
Lighting electric hot water heating
systems electric heat pumps for heating
and cooling an electric oven we can make
these buildings all electric if we're in
Detroit or LA or in Houston one of the
cities where people love their cars will
of course install some electric vehicle
charging stations we'll have some backup
battery systems because all three
electricity and energy grids are
collapsing under the weight of heat
waves in the climate crisis but we can
Electrify
buildings now is it simple is it easy to
Electrify buildings no there's
challenges and opportunities we have to
solve a finance problem we have to solve
a Workforce problem we have to solve a
data
problem electrification can cost 10 20
$30,000 per
building and that's not affordable for
the average American but what we can do
is most Americans can't afford to buy a
home on their own and so we have a
mortgage and so we studied the mortgage
market and found ways to amortize and
spread out The Upfront cost of building
electrification over 15 years so that
the monthly payment is Affordable and
lower in some instances than what
families pay for fossil
fuels we have a Workforce problem in
that like Europe there's a short of
skilled electricians and technicians
Across America to deliver on these
projects uh mayor Eric Adams in New York
City has asked us to train and hire
3,000 vulnerable and low-income
individuals ex offenders gang members
military veterans with PTSD formerly
homeless folks to train them in building
electrification we had a gang a street
gang kind of come to us and say look if
you if you guys hire us and give us jobs
we will shut down our street gang we had
a crew of workers who who had been
locked up in Riker's Island our New York
City jail and we trained them we hired
them we took them back to Riker's Island
they installed installed solar panels in
the parking
lot we have a data problem every
building is unique like a snowflake so
in order to make sure we have the right
size of electrification equipment for
that building to unhook it from fossil
fuels we have to collect data and make
sure we specify and recommend the right
equipment we've been working with the
Bezos Earth fund to aggregate all of the
data on all 125 million buildings Across
America so that families can search for
their address get an electrification
work plan hand it to a local well-
trained electrician who we've trained
and hired these are good jobs that can't
be outsourced so that every family has
access to the data that they
need we've recently started working with
itha New York where Cornell is located
and San Jose and Meno Park these are
cities that have committed to
decarbonize 100% by the year 2030 and
and A2 years so we're going to go
building to building and
move each building off of fossil fuels
and make them all electric so we've got
6 and a half years but there's dozens of
cities across the country where we're
working with Partners Portland Oregon
Denver Atlanta Chicago to Electrify
buildings at scale
electrification is possible it's not
simple it's not easy but it is possible
and what that means is
if we can Electrify one building it
means that we can Electrify a whole
block of buildings if we can Electrify a
block of buildings it means that we can
Electrify a neighborhood if we can
Electrify a neighborhood it means that
we can Electrify a city and if we can
Electrify a city that means we can
Electrify a country there's a saying you
have to be the change that you wish to
see in the world by doing this we're
going to create great jobs there's going
to be massive economic and public health
outcomes but we also are Inspire cities
and countries around the world to
Electrify and we'll be able to look our
children in the eyes when they ask us
and say that we're doing everything we
can to reduce emissions at speed and
scale to fight the most damaging impacts
of the climate catastrophe thank
you